he took his will away he took his he
made the guy
think that the guy no longer had a say
in the fight
that he couldn't control things that are
sanji was in control he made him
that's brilliant took away the runner
rant yep
brian that adam sonja is special but
that's why
yeah he's athletic there's a lot of
athletic guys out there but he's very
athletic
and very works out hard and everything
else and very determined and
driven but he's very smart and he's kind
of
spirituality i know people going to say
what that is
they're cracking each other no no no
there's a lot more to it i hope
you're starting to learn that you know
that and he does he
he's he's got a belief that
there's an energy there's a other force
out there that
if you're in control of it he can be an
ally to you it's part of your strength
it's part of what you bring in that ring
call it belief called supreme confidence
all those words that make us feel more
comfortable than
spirituality or whatever but
it's a knowledge that he's in complete
control
of his environment of himself he's
responsible for himself
and that another man don't control him
no matter how tough it gets it's still
your choice
how you gonna deal with that tough spot
what you're gonna behave like and that
you have a supreme confidence that the
knowledge of
that knowing that you're in control of
it
that that it that it is in your
wheelhouse to make those choices
to know that you have it it's kind of
like a sprinter knowing that he's
that he's got 4-3 speed and a 40.
oh he knows that's there
well this guy knows that he's got this
ability
you get me ken he knows that he's got
the ability to overcome
he knows that the when the cloud comes
and it comes to all of us
when that wave comes that can consume us
smother us choke us
he knows he can it ain't coming he's he
he knows he has the ability to put it on
another guy but
it ain't getting on him why because he
won't let it
because he knows those things as
controllable as his legs
as controllable as his fist now we're
getting deep i get it but it's it's it
to me it's
it's it's not deep it's it's it's what
the special ones are all about
it's what muhammad ali was about people
thought they were going to a funeral
inside here
with him they did they thought my guy's
going to die
but the strength of ali was in his right
hand even though he knocked out former
with that
it was his inner belief the inner
sanctuary of himself that
that internal belief
this guy that lasagna he's got it
he's got that he's got that
and he knows it's always your choice
until
you make it the other guy's choice he
knows that
under pressure sometimes you just give
it up you think that oh he
he took it from me he just took it from
me there's no such thing as those kung
fu movies
where they and i please rob get this up
for me even though it's going to be
graphic
no no he's going to get up it's going to
be a little graphic but you know
yeah and you go right through the guy's
chest and you take the heart out
no that doesn't exist but it happens
spiritually it does it happens people do
that
they take it out but it can't happen if
you don't let it happen
he and this guy knows that ali knew that
uh he ali reached right into performance
chest and pulled it right out and said
he just didn't put it up there you know
but that's what he did
yeah he made foreman feel like foreman
had no say that night
that's a lie but the great ones know the
difference between the truth and the lie
and desire to sign you from i don't know
what his background is
but i know that it's something that has
gotten them to this
place yeah and it's got nothing to do
with the physical stuff
and um